um i guess i don't know how like
people like girls can't tell what i'm
into them
i guess like
that's my problem how do they not know
have you told them you're into them
oh well yeah that that's another problem
like
no that's the only oh that's the only
problem
tell them they can't tell i'm into them
did you tell them
no no that's what not you talking about
they're not gonna designate which is
only hold up
it's like they have to guess if i think
it hard enough
they're gonna know it oh i think i put
my pants what do you
look at my face
doing this live sometimes it's really
hard to be like
mm-hmm oh i don't even hide it i don't
hide it no no no there was a time i was
like i was
i was no i was scratching it i was like
oh no
no she about though you know what you
know what
that is just me that's just me i'm not
into hints
subtle hints obvious hints big hints
small hints
you're right here in front of the person
say what you want
say it use your words be right there i
have
i don't know i have i'm not really good
at telling people
that i'm into them okay okay well well
women are going to want you to tell them
that you're into them
well if women can't tell you're into
them it's probably because you don't
tell them that you're into them right
it's like if you don't it's like if you
came on here and you're like man women
can't tell that i want to go on a date
with them
did you ask them on a date no
i don't want my friends like that one of
my girlfriends like that we're chilling
even girl not even guys
people in general because girls girls
you're good with that yeah yeah
i flicked my hair this is that girl's
flirt
that was it that's not the problem you
know the problem is
they get mad yeah when you don't see
your ambiguous
ass bro i was in our one of my friends
what my homies when the club right we
chillin
we chillin and there's like we i ordered
drinks that's what i do yeah you need to
chip
no bro nah
i was like yo ordering drinks whatever
we drinking is my me
her my sister we drinking
we drinking parties going on over here
uh what about how party's going over
there say hello
anyways so my friends are standing there
she's just standing there and i'm like
yo what's up
hey you weird you mad with she's like
distant and trying to i see she's trying
to hit
angles i mean i'm trying to be like yo
what's up so you're like beat but she's
just just distant
right and and she's just trying to give
angle i'm like yo what are you doing
oh there's this goddess i think is
really cute okay
so what's she doing well you know my
thing
and i was like huh yeah i'm just doing
my thing
okay highlight me whenever you're done
doing your thing 15
20 30 45 an hour and a half fast
nothing happens me i'm like all right
it's about to be two
uh in the morning so yo you i tell my
sister you you hungry
she's like yeah yo we finna go eat hop
in
we get to the place it's right next it's
close by we start ordering
she's pissed off pout and i'm like yo
what the hell is wrong with you
like well you didn't let me do my thing
that was like do what things like well
the guy's there
and you know i was trying to get his
attention
i'm like [ __ ] how well you know
i was doing my thing and i'm like
you wasn't doing what do you mean doing
your thing you want to go in [ __ ]
it's like well you didn't let me because
you we left i'm like boo boo honey
chicken cherry child honey bunny bunch
with a slice of lime
and a cherry on top what thing it's been
an hour and a half you standing there
sipping on that drink i mean
girl what are you doing and she got
pissed off and i'm like you know what
you need to talk to mother
you're just there being i hate when you
do that and then you complain that
nothing is happening you staying there
[Music]
sometimes you your way to flirt is to
ignore people
it's like yo i thought you know what get
up i paid the bill
let's get it let's go we're going in i'm
like yo we're back at the spot
the guy's there go talk to him and then
you'll know
he even if it rejects you you'll know if
he says no
you'll know if he says he has a girl at
least you'll be in the know but you're
going to be there
on the side of the bar um trying to um
put some lipstick and then get
no go talk to a mother that's also part
of equality you wanna
go get some go ask you know what you
know how many girls
that's been since i was in since i was
in elementary school
how many girls be like oh you got a girl
oh i was interested and i'm like for how
long
oh for the past two years [ __ ]
what
what i'm going to make and then now
you're going to tell me
i got a whole situation i got a whole
girlfriend and you tell me
now like not when i'm locked up oh oh i
oh oh you got a girl now all right
oh well that's too bad what the [ __ ] i
mean it's too bad oh
cuz i gotta i had a crush on you i got
kind of a thang for you for like the
past two years
really deep crush you know i really i
couldn't stop thinking [ __ ] you're
telling me now
yo girls girls
this ain't it this ain't it
how you expect them to know
i can't i guess but like and i don't
know
like i guess i just i have to like i
don't know how to tell them you know
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's definitely
scary to get rejected you know but
better to get rejected to ask you to get
rejected than to never ask
and still get rejected because true
because if
you never ask you'll never know and
you'll never get a result at least if
you try then
you know but you might be missing out on
all kinds of opportunities to have great
relationships with people just because
you're letting your fear hold you back
yeah
you know you're kind of stuck in
purgatory you're not going to hell or
heaven you're just stuck in no man's
land
so just go for it girls don't know i'm
into
did you ask them no yo this job don't
want to hire me did you apply
no well [ __ ] what you want me to do for
you gotta apply
i can't help you i don't want to smooth
that yeah this job don't want to hire me
did you apply
no then [ __ ] why are you still here go
apply for your job
well you know it's kind of hard to be
rejected
i don't know what to tell you man i'm
going to reiterate the same point i made
before
[ __ ] need to put in some effort
you guys
i get it it hurts there's no way around
it
take some risks don't be a coward
everybody's hurt i can't put it any
other way
sometimes you know and as far as like
the whole expectations brad dealt with
that so many times
girls come to me multiple years later
how come we never went on a date
how am i supposed to win when did you
make yourself interested the whole time
how you never said anything
you didn't suggest anything i was
oblivious
yeah but remember that one time where we
at that party
you mean the one where i caught you by
surprise there yeah
what about it she goes well when i was
there
bro
bro i'm hot now
god damn this is real
if she played with her hair if she
glances at you
how do i know she doesn't think i'm a
creep maybe she's
granted she's like damn that guy might
follow me home i don't know why she's
looking at me
oh bro listen in this day and age
especially
you think i'ma just take a chance
when you feel stronger than i do and now
it's guys too apparently because this
guy was like yeah well you know
i don't i'm not even that mad at them
for partially
partially only a little bit because like
of the climate we live in
going up to the wrong girl saying he's
creepy no he just tried a shot
stop complaining because if this [ __ ]
was christian bale you'd have been like
hey man you could bail me out again
you would have said yes guys ladies
please
if you're interested take a chance go
for it
take it it's time girls it's time this
time uh but he's gonna think i'm too
masculine i
i never heard no man no as long as you
know like hey [ __ ] can i get some
i know you like today i got time [ __ ]
as long as you're not going on some hood
i promise you if you go up to the guys
like hey i actually thought you were
cute i want to strike up a conversation
they might be thrown off because we're
not used to it
but i ain't never heard of a guy who was
interested in a girl she came up to him
first and then he wasn't interested i
have never heard that no
no i have never you know what i've never
heard of a dude who wanted to bang a
girl
they were chit chatting they were
talking and the girls like i want a bank
tonight and the guy was like nah
i never heard of that and the guy was
like if he wants you and you come
forward he'd be like
oh yeah let's go
yo get the playstation controller we
playing nah bro
playstation six let's go [ __ ] i never
heard of that so that's a lot bro
never no i never ladies if you don't
believe me guys if you're right here
you're watching right now if you've been
attracted to a girl she asked you out
first would you consider rejecting her a
girl you were really interested
if you would put that in the comments i
would love to hear this testimony we're
not even flaming you we just want to
know i don't believe it
i don't know cause you know i want to
step forward first
what dave never ever heard of it one
[ __ ] don't want to brag that a girl he
thinks is hot came up to him
and i don't the reaction might be like
oh oh work
oh word yeah oh hell oh wow yes
well i'm flat that's the most you're
gonna get or he's not interested and
he's gonna say no now you just
feel how we feel and quality right
bruh no listen triggered okay let's go
man speaking of rejection right i was
telling this
and some girl's like yeah but we do know
what it feels like to be rejected i've
been rejected before
i was like oh really tell me about that
rejection she's like yeah well one time
i liked this guy and then me and my
friend went up and he said he wasn't
interested
i'm like so how did you ask him she's
like oh i did it my friend said
i know someone who could be interested
in you and she's kind of cute huh
you went up to a dude and you had
somebody else that's how you count
how old were you she said 10th grade the
[ __ ] i get all your sh
all of them all of them you finish this
video the bad
the bag uh the pillow
uh everything the covers to all you sh
get the [ __ ] out that's the thing
it's really whenever you talk whenever
you talk because he's gone
he's gone he's gone he went for a walk
he went to get something to eat
anyways i've seen that happen happen so
often
so often no no but we get rejected we
know what rejection is
no no ladies no not
at the same rate as men
do period oh you're back no i'm just you
do not yes
i'm triggered bro nah bro listen if you
guys are watching 50
of you not subscribe subscribe right now
y'all got me this triggered you're going
to subscribe
and like the video or else i'll come and
slap that [ __ ] up not the ladies i would
never do that but
i'm gonna touch nobody listen just do it
bro just stop playing with me talking
about you know anything else you want to
say yeah that's what i was like
girls no no you don't know at the same
rate as man
you don't because that's the name of the
game we do the approaching
you will finally say yes or no it is
what it is even in the dance world the
guys are gonna go ask the girls
girls are not as rejected as guys girls
if a girl
don't dance in a dance night it's
because she's not asking she's just
staying there
that's it that is it ladies you do not
at the same rate as men and that's even
on
the dating apps even there the dating
apps are made so that
you choose and you reject and we have to
come forward
right so no you don't know and you're
the one that has you're in the
position that you have to be entertained
most of the time
you're the one that do the blocking or
the unmatched or that
you know what i mean because he's not
interesting or whatever what not so no
you do not know
at the same rate as men what it's like
to be rejected
now that being said if you want
something go get it
you know what what pisses me off it's
not so much that they don't go
ask do you what pisses me off
is that when they have no result they
get pissed off
i've heard numerous women trash a man
because he was he was not man he doesn't
get no sign of no clue
he needs to get a clue because i was
there sitting with my fine ass at the
bar
nail done hair done everything big
and he did not even catch it
no you want that get that and then we'll
talk
but we said that already anyways um
[Music]
oh